.
HAPPY FIFTH YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
>> Laura: I AM LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
ELECT THEM OR ELSE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
JOE BIDEN IS A LIAR.
BECAUSE HE CAN'T BEAT
REPUBLICANS FAIR AND SQUARE HE
IS TRYING TO CRIMINALIZE THEIR
EXISTANCY AND FABICATES
SCENARIOS WITH HALF TRUTHS.
>> A NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE CONDONING POLITICAL
VIOLENCE OR REMAINING SILENT.
I WE CAN'T ALLOW THIS TO GROW --
WE MUST CONFRONT IT NOW.
>> Laura: CONFRONT WHAT?
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH JOE
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS?
HOW DO YOU CONFRONT THEM?
WITH SURVEILLANCE OR HOUNDING
THEM.
TRYING TO GET THEM FIRED OR
CANCELED.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE A PUBLIC
SERVANT AND NOT THE PUBLIC'S
MASTER.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING MORE
IRRESPONSIBLE THAN A PRESIDENT
THAT TELLS THE WORLD AMERICA IS
A DEMOCRACY ONLY IF HIS PARTY
WINS.
THAT'S WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
BEEN DOING SINCE HE WAS SWORN
INTO OFFICE.
LAST NIGHT WAS EMBARRASSING FOR
BOTH THE PRESIDENT AND OUR
COUNTRY.
NO POLICY, NO EFFORT TO BRING
THE COUNTRY TOGETHER.
JUST FURY TOWARDS REPUBLICANS.
>> IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE
AMERICAN 300 ELECTION DENIERS ON
THE BALLOT ACROSS AMERICA THIS
YEAR, WE CAN'T IGNORE THE IMPACT
THIS IS HAVING ON OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S DAMAGING.
IT'S CORROSIVE AND DESTRUCTIVE.
>> Laura: THEN IN THE DEMOCRATS
LOSE AND KARI LAKE AND DIXON AND
SMILEY AND DON ARE ELECTED.
BIDEN WON'T RECOGNIZE THEM AS
LEADERS.
THEY ARE ALL ENEMIES OF
DEMOCRACY.
THEN WHY WOULD DEMOCRATS EVER
COOPERATE WITH THEM?
GIVEN THE TRACK RECORD OF THE
SLEAZY BIDEN TEAM, I WOULD NOT
BE SURPRISED IF THEY TOOK THEIR
IMPLICIT THREATS A STEP FURTHER
AND USED THE FULL FORCE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE THE
LIVES OF THESE NEWLY ELECTED
REPUBLICANS MISERABLE.
I AM TALKING AUDITS.
PHONEY INVESTIGATIONS AND
SURVEILLANCE.
THEY HAVE DONE IT BEFORE.
THEY HAVE THE WHOLE DEEP STATE.
THEY ARE READY TO DO THEIR
BIDDING.
THEY ARE ISSUING FINAL WARNINGS.
>> THE PRESIDENT DECIDED IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ISSUE ONE FINAL
WARNING ON THIS ISSUE TO MAKE
VERY CLEAR WE HAVE PEOPLE OUT
THERE STILL PEDALLING THE BIG
LIE AND OF COURSE, THE HORRIBLE
INCIDENT INVOLVING SPEAKER
PELOSI AND YEAR FAMILY SHOWING
THE RISING THREAT OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: A FINAL WARNING.
WHAT A BIZARRE NEGATIVE CLOSE
ARGUMENT TO AMERICA:
IF DEMOCRATS DON'T WIN THEN
AMERICA FAILED AND WE ARE NO
LONGER A DEMOCRACY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE ENGAGED IN
PROJECTION.
THEY CLAIM REPUBLICANS ARE
AGAINST DEMOCRACY BUT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE.
THEY ARE QUESTIONING THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE MID-TERMS
BECAUSE THE CANDIDATES ARE
ILLEGITIMATE BECAUSE THEY ARE
MEGA-MAGA.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
TRYING TO SUCCEED WHERE THEY
FAILED IN 2020.
TO SUPPRESS THE RIGHT OF VOTERS
AND SUBVERT THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM.
THAT MEANS DENYING YOUR RIGHT TO
VOTE AND DECIDING WHETHER YOUR
VOTE EVEN COUNT.
INSTEAD OF WAITING UNTIL THE
ELECTION IS OVER.
>> Laura: LET'S FAST FORWARD FOR
A MOMENT HERE.
THESE WORDS DO MATTER.
WHAT IF LISTENING TO THE
PRESIDENT THE WORLD BEGINS TO
TREAT AMERICA AS A PARIAH STATE
ON THE VERGE OF REVOLUTION?
WHAT IS OTHER COUNTRIES REFUSE
TO COOPERATE WITH US ON ISSUES
LIKE UKRAINE AND TAIWAN?
WOULD THAT MAKE BIDEN HAPPY?
IT WOULD MAKE THIS SO-CALLED
HISTORIAN HAPPY.
>> WE COULD BE 6 DAYS AWAY FROM
LOSING OUR RULE OF LAW AND
LOSING A SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
ELECTIONS WE ALL CAN RELY ON.
A HISTORIAN WILL SAY WHETHER WE
WILL BE A DEMOCRACY IN THE
FUTURE, WHETHER OUR CHILDREN
WILL BE ARRESTED AND KILLED.
WE ARE ON THE EDGE OF A BRUTAL
SYSTEM.
>> Laura: IF BEING A BLOW HARD
IS A QUALIFICATION TO WIN THE
PULITZER, HE DESERVES ONE.
HE WAS INVITED TO THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH OTHER THINKERS IN
AUGUST BY BIDEN HIMSELF TO CRAFT
MESSAGES ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
FROM THE EDGE OF A BRUTAL
AUTHORITARIAN SYSTEM WHERE OUR
CHILDREN COULD BE ARRESTED.
THAT WOULD LEAVE LEFT WING
ACTIVISTS TO EXTREME MEASURES.
EXTREME MEASURES SHOULD BE TAKEN
TO PREVENT THESE ILLEGITIMATE
CANDIDATES FROM WING.
FOR A PARTY ABOUT POLICING
SPEECH IT SHOULD WATCH ITS OWN
WORDS.
THE PEOPLE WHO APPEAR ON MSNBC
MORNING SHOW THEY THINK THEY ARE
BETTER THAN YOU.
THIS HILARIOUS HULLED.
-- HEADLINE:
IS AMERICA READY TO TRADE
DEMOCRACY FOR CHEAP GAS?
THEY ARE IN FULL MELTDOWN MODE.
ANOTHER SCRIBE IS CLAIMING THAT
INSURRECTIONISTS WILL TAKE POWER
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND BLAMES
LOW INFORMATION VOTERS WHO WILL
ELECT THEM.
VOTERS WHO ARE BLAMING BIDEN FOR
INFLATION.
THEIR DEMOCRACY PITCH IS
HYPOCRISY.
THEY REFUSED TO CONFIRM THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THEY WANTED TRUMP STOPPED BEFORE
HE STARTED.
>> I PICKED UP THE "WASHINGTON
POST" AND THE HEADLINE READ
TRUMP TAKES POWER!
>> [BOOING].
>> I DON'T THINK SO!
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOT AMERICA.
HIS CABINET IS NOT AMERICA.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I HAVE THOUGHT AN AWFUL LOT
ABOUT BLOWING UP THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> Laura: OH!
AS THE "ANGLE" SAID MANY TIMES
THIS IS A SAD ENDING FOR THE
PARTY OF FDR AND JFK.
YOU CAN'T BROWBEAT SOMEONE INTO
LOVING YOU OR VOTING FOR YOU.
WE TALKED ABOUT BIDEN'S LIES.
BUT THE NEW CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT IS OUR ONLY HOPE OF
SAVING A GOVERNMENT FOR THE
PEOPLE.
OUR POLITICAL LEADERS FELT LIKE
THEY COULD KEEP POLICIES IN
PLACE LIKE OPEN BORDERS AND
FREE-TRADE WITH CHINA, NO MATTER
WHO WAS IN OFFICE.
THAT'S COMING TO AN END.
THE PEOPLE ARE ON THE MARCH.
WE ARE GETTING NEW LEADERS.
LEADERS WHO TRUST AND LISTEN TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE OLD ESTABLISHMENT HACKS WHO
RAN THIS COUNTRY INTO THE
GROUND, THEY WILL BE LOOKING F